- Hello, everyone.
Welcome to another YouTube hangout.
Super excited to be here
with an old friend, Amy,
from Savvy, Sexy, Social,
and a new website,
Vlog Like a Boss, to celebrate the launch
of her new book that just came out
on how you can have success
as a vlogger on YouTube.
Amy, great to have you back on.
- Evan, I'm so happy to be back.
Thank you for having me.
I love that I can join you in
this whole book club thing.
Isn't that cool?
- Yeah, I didn't know that
our books were going to be
so closely, a.
- I know.
It was so weird.
- It's fun.
Anyway, so today, we're talkin' about tips
and tricks for YouTube success.
I want to touch on your book
and everything that you're
highlighted in there,
but kind of the high-level first tip
that you want to give out.
What do you think holds
people back on YouTube
from having the success
that maybe they deserve
or should have?
What do you think?
- I think it can be a little overwhelming
for people to consider talking on camera.
I mean, even I, my
sister's a business owner,
and she's still trying to wrap her mind
around the whole thing, you know.
It's not just like listening
to me doesn't always mean
it's going to happen,
but a lot of people look
at the camera, and they're like, oh,
that's a little intimidating.
I think that holds a lot of people back.
That's sort of like the first thing
cause we're in our own
heads a little bit too much.
And also, YouTube is kind
of a monster to take on.
It's not the same as all
the other social networks
because if you're going
into YouTube fresh,
it's fresh, and there's
not a whole lot happening.
So that can take some time to
kind of grow momentum there.
So it's all of those things considered
that can make somebody kind of shut down
and not get started at all.
But I think the biggest
issue with that barrier
is not really zeroing in on
the importance of your message.
Because I think once you do that,
a lot of fears and
walls start to fall down
because if something is so
important that you've got
to get it out there, and you know someone
that needs to hear it, and
you have this information
inside of you or this
entertainment inside of you
that you just must share,
when you focus on that and that
becomes the important thing,
we can start to not be
so afraid of the things
that are holding us back internally.
It's the importance of the audience
and what you have to deliver for them.
- So just as you're saying that,
we already have people
joining live watching.
- [Amy] Cool.
- And if you guys watching live,
if you have a question for Amy,
put it in all caps, so it's easy to find.
Clashgamerxp is asking,
talking on camera looks scary,
and he's concerned about
the idea that the video's
going to be there forever.
- [Amy] Right.
- So this first video that you have
that may not be good quality.
It's your first attempt, that
it's going to live forever.
And people will always be able to see it.
What advice do you have there?
- So everyone always asks
this question, right.
Like, oh, I'm so much
better than I was before.
Maybe I can delete my old stuff,
and I actually think that that's
something you shouldn't do,
and you should be totally
fine with publishing it.
The luxury we have on YouTube
is building the archive.
We want that video to be there forever.
It's not very many places
where we can create
something that's valuable for someone
and it still be working for
us for five, six years later.
One of my most popular videos
is from a very long time ago.
You know, maybe my hair wasn't perfect.
Maybe the environment wasn't perfect.
Lighting wasn't that good,
but that video is still crushing it,
and it's helping people.
So I would challenge you to think how,
if I'm going to be embarrassed
of this video down the road,
have it be for the wrong reasons
so that the right reasons are so strong,
like how well you
delivered the information
and how confident you
were and how evergreen
that is going to be to help
you over the long-term.
That it's going to stay
there and work for you,
and you won't want to delete it.
I actually think it's just
so important to hit publish,
and practice, practice,
practice, practice.
The only way to practice
and we're preaching
to the choir here cause Evan
practices the publish button
every single day very regularly,
many times a day.
You got to do that and
get the content out there
to get the feedback,
to get better, to grow.
And if I didn't have those first videos
that are like (hums) just okay,
I wouldn't be here right now.
And that's what keeps people, I think,
from getting better is because
they get too much, again,
in their own heads about
it and they're like,
ah, well, I don't really
like how it looks,
so I'm just going to stop.
Well, it's not going to get better then.
You've got to practice, so
I would say, get into it.
Be okay with the fact, I say this
from the stage all the time.
When I'm speaking about video, I say,
you're first video is going to suck.
Like it's going to be bad.
- [Evan] Right.
- Let's just put it out there.
It's going to be bad, so
you better just get it done,
and then, move on to the next one
and the next one, and
they're going to suck
much more progressively
less than the previous.
And you'll be in a good place before long.
- I think, too, it shows you the journey.
- Yeah, I love that.
- A journey of inspiration.
Right?
If people look at you know, and say,
Amy, you're such a natural.
You're so great at this.
And meanwhile, you've
done all these videos.
Like, go back. Look at my first one.
It wasn't so good.
- [Amy] Yeah.
- And they can see that journey
as an inspiration for the
work that you're doing.
- Absolutely, it sort
of meta though for me,
cause I get the luxury of being like,
okay, I could take it as a total
time to be like sad
inside when someone says,
oh, my gosh, Amy, I was
so afraid to make a video.
But then I watched your first videos,
and I'm thinking, I'm going
to go ahead and do it, too.
Because if you can do it, and
those were your first videos,
then I can do it, too.
That could sound really bad like,
I would take that personal, but I don't.
Because I sort of have this meta situation
of my job is to make you want to do video,
so my journey makes you want to do video.
Cause you can see how far I've come,
and therefore, you can, too.
But I think you can feel that way even
if you're not trying to tell people how
to share their story with video.
You can still feel that way
about your own database.
It's got to be there, and we
see it all the time on YouTube
where people feel like their
YouTube channel looks so bare.
Well, that's because you're
afraid to hit publish
on everything, so just get it out there,
and do your best work.
- Do you have a recommendation for
how much people should be practicing.
- Well, here's the crazy
thing is that going
to YouTube Next Stop, they
really brought me back in terms
of like how often you
should be publishing.
Cause I was publishing super regularly.
I was one of the only people there
that had a regular schedule.
Everyone else was like,
whenever I can get it done.
I was publishing three
days a week religiously
for a number of years.
But industry standard on
YouTube is once a week.
And I found that interesting
because I do think
that's a good recommendation
if you're just getting started.
Do a really good job on
your once a week video,
and then learn how to market it.
Because when you do that,
and you don't just get
into the churn of doing
videos all the time,
you learn how to market really well.
And then, every video
works its hardest for you
because at the beginning, especially,
you've got to get some momentum there
to start growing subscribers and views.
So it is better to make
something really good,
and then spend time marketing it,
so you can make every project
after it matter even more.
But I can also see people
posting more than that
because it's 2017, and
we've got smart phones.
And there's a million
different ways to make video.
And soon, I think we're
going to be more seamlessly
live-streaming to YouTube with our phones.
So there's a lot of ways you
can publish more regularly,
but I think we should
be thinking about that
and adding in the
component of how much time
does it take to make
the video and market it.
So that we're making the
most of all of that time.
Cause on YouTube, you're going
to need it if you want to grow.
- So, I mean, I'm sure you get into this
in your Vlog Like a Boss book.
You guys can go check that out,
but in terms of the marketing side.
So if I've now made a new vlog, you know,
Evan visits New York
city, and here's my day.
What am I now doing to market
it for the rest of the week?
- Well, I think what's
really cool is first of all,
really staying focused on a theme of like,
what is this video about?
It's not just every
single second of the day.
Let's share it.
But what is this video really about?
What is the take-away
we want people to have?
Because I think that's going to help you
have more soundbites within.
You can market a video
as a whole, you know,
across your social media,
but there might also be
bits and pieces inside that
video that you can share.
Maybe there's a good Instagram moment.
Maybe there's a behind the scenes thing
you can be doing with Snapchat.
I don't think people think
about the repurposing
of a video quite enough
because we put so much energy
into creating one project.
But there's also probably
10 different things in there
that would make that one
piece of content marketable.
And so how can you livestream
something on Instagram
while you're making that project
to get the anticipation up about it?
Is there a screen capture from that video
that you can post to
Instagram with a quote
that would make it interesting
for someone to click
in your bio to go watch that video.
I think that it comes down
to the focus of the video.
What's the take-away need to be?
So that you constantly are
thinking about how to make
this project better.
Of little soundbites and
opportunities to leverage
across all of the social platforms,
especially in a place like Facebook
where if you made something for YouTube,
it's not always the best
project for Facebook.
So what is really cool in that video
that you could share there?
I just did, some people know
me from musical book reviews
that I've done for Gary Vaynerchuk
cause I guess I'm a Gary fangirl,
and I finally did my third music video,
but it was for myself this time.
And I just did that on
launch day, on the 31st.
But for Facebook, you
know, it's not quite,
in my opinion, as interesting of a video
cause you have to really
be moving around a lot
to pull people in.
So we just took a 20 second clip of it,
and uploaded it to
Facebook, so that you could
click over to YouTube to
watch the whole thing.
That way if you're pulled in by it,
you can take that next step
and have the full experience over there.
So I think you have to just
think about what is the context
of every network and how
do we make it perfect
for that network.
And that's how you'll find
all these opportunities
throughout your one video
project to market it.
- I wonder how much of your marketing
is based off of leveraging
your other networks,
like, going to Instagram and Snapchat
and Facebook and Twitter
and then driving traffic
back to it versus using
other people's networks
to, I mean, so like this, you know?
I'm introducing you
to my audience.
- Yeah.
- People may already know you.
How much of that do you
do with your videos,
or do you feel like you get the best bang
just trying to build up your own platforms
on the other other social networks?
- I think collaboration
is super important,
but at the same time, I will
also be the first to say
I could probably have done
it even more intentionally
than I have in the last six years.
But I've actually had some
amazing collaborations
that have done great work for me.
My personal opinion is if
I continue to make the best
possible project for my
community as possible,
they're going to be the best
word of mouth of all time.
This social proof that Evan's like,
I want to have Amy on and maybe somebody
will find her interesting
and go over there
is huge for me, but no
one's going to love me more
than my community who I'm
making my content for.
And once you become a part
of it, you kind of grow
because of that.
In terms of the social networks,
I definitely leverage any momentum I can.
I find my content on
YouTube is so important,
especially in those first couple of days
where it's really trying
to find it's footing
in the YouTube world of
referrals and search.
I'm going to send everyone to
YouTube to check that stuff out.
I'm not necessarily going
outside of my own network
for every single upload.
I think it has to depend on the situation
because again, this is for my community.
They're the best network I could have.
So I'm going to go to
Instagram and let them know
with stories that I'm
pushing the publish button.
And then I go to Twitter
to like drop a GIF in
to be like, hey, you guys,
there's a video coming.
And then there's this whole sort of like,
get the anticipation up, so
that people go and watch.
I think that's what people
don't think enough about
is how can you leverage those networks?
But do it in a way that
makes sense for each
of those places, so that
people will actually
take the call to action.
Cause just because you
posted a link somewhere
doesn't mean people are going to click it.
How are you actually making
it worth their while.
And so that's why I
leverage my own community
more than I leverage everyone else's.
But when I actually have a
value prop for everyone else's,
I'm going to go there and
say, hey, what do you think
about teaming up on this
because I think your community
would love it.
- I like it.
I like it.
We're getting a question
from Linger Magazine
that kind of touches on what
you said at the beginning
about the different platforms basically,
trying to understand the difference
between YouTube, Vimeo, everywhere else
that you want to be posting video.
You know, is YouTube dead?
Should we still be focused here?
What are your thoughts?
- So I love when people
ask me if YouTube is dead
because it's the second
largest search engine
in the world to Google,
and that's its adopted mom.
So it's like really?
Is YouTube dead?
I think what I wish people
would think more about
is the type of video
in all of these places
and how different they actually are.
The other social networks
that are coming to light now
are actually making YouTube even stronger
because of the conversation
a video as a whole
that's happening because of it.
So let's paint like a really
literal picture though.
When you go to YouTube to watch a video,
when you clicked on this video,
you saw headline and a thumbnail,
and that pulled you in.
A notification maybe, a
headline, and a thumbnail.
That pulled you in.
When you're on Facebook,
you're hanging out
with your friends.
You're stalking your ex.
You're checking in on Grandma.
You know, Grandma's checkin'
in on the grandkids.
Like, there's a whole
different situation happening
on Facebook when a video
shows up on your feed
and just starts playing without any audio.
So that's a very unintentional view.
So even though we've
been there making friends
and building communities
so it seems like it's a lot
easier to get views over there,
it's a different type of view.
We have a little bit of a, not harder,
but just a different type
of way of pulling people
in than we do on YouTube.
So that's why I say a video on YouTube
is not always the same for Facebook,
so we have to think about that.
When you're considering Vimeo,
usually I say in that case, you know,
is your video a fine piece of art
that needs to be paid for
or only really respected
by a very small niche community
and not on the intention
of being discovered
on the second largest
search engine in the world?
Then, go to Vimeo.
Then that makes sense.
I will use Vimeo for
more course-like content,
things that are behind the
paywall or behind an opt-in wall
or something like that versus YouTube
just because I like the customization.
But that's just a preference.
I could use YouTube, too, for that.
But YouTube, you're being discovered,
and people are deciding to come to you
because of your thumbnail and headline.
It's not the same as an
auto-play on Facebook,
so there's that.
Personally, I think video on Instagram
is what made it almost lose to Snapchat,
which is why them stealing stories
made it all kind of work out again.
Because nobody is sitting on Instagram
and just watching a video.
They're scrolling and
double-tapping and scrolling
and double-tapping and that's it.
That's all they want to do.
They want to look at pretty
things and like them.
So how do you make video for that context?
Now, we see those like Boomerangs
because you don't have to
pay attention to those.
They're hilarious.
And then Twitter is
GIF-land in my opinion.
Or GIF-land depending on what you prefer.
You have to remember,
people are on the go.
What speed are they looking at content
in all these places?
How do they like to watch
it, and what makes sense?
It's going to make you go, oh my gosh.
Every one of these needs
a different kind of video.
And that's where the wheels
start to turn on repurposing
and marketing properly.
- Love it.
Sebastian is writing, Evan, how can I buy
a book from Germany?
I don't know if he's talking
about my book or yours,
but mine is on Amazon.
We have lots
of different customers.
- Yeah, Amazon.
Buy 'em both.
They're on there.
(laughs)
- Are you, do you have
like, multiple versions?
You have an ebook version.
Do you have an audio version?
Is that coming?
What's?
- The audio version will be out later.
I have the hardback, paperback,
and Kindle in Amazon right now.
So if you go to VlogLikeABoss.com,
you can find the links
to everything there,
but yeah, we have
everything except for audio.
But audio is on its way.
- Cool, are you doing the audio yourself?
- Oh, yeah, oh, my gosh.
So I just did my first like, book reading
at a signing last night,
which was super emotional.
So I had a hard time getting through it,
but I feel like because I make videos
it's only right that people
get to hear my personality
come through in my own book.
There's no way I could
go with any other option.
- I was the exact same way.
It was fun.
- [Amy] Yeah.
- It was pure fire
sitting there recording.
- [Amy] It's so fun.
- I'm excited to hear yours.
Okay, ArtandHomesteading, to
what degree is personality
more important than content,
more or less important
than content?
In other words, should
I spend more time on my
in front of camera skills or
my research slash subjects?
- I think you need to know your game.
I mean, that's really
important, especially these days
where if it's as easy as taking
a selfie to get attention,
the competition for being a
thought leader in your space
is going to become much higher.
You need to know your stuff,
so content is extremely important.
I would also say it's important
because I don't read a prompter.
I don't have a script.
So when I'm looking at
the lens of a camera
like it's a person, I should probably know
what I'm going to say,
so that has a lot to do
with that, too, just prepping
for that conversation.
So content is extremely important.
But that's where the personality
just takes its own way
into the situation.
I'm not customizing my personality, right?
I'm just telling you what I know,
and so this is my personality.
It's the one I was born with.
It's the only one I get.
It's the only one I need.
And that's what, you'll
read that in the book,
and I think a lot of
people deal with that.
And I did, too.
I wasn't a ham for the
camera when I was growing up.
I just figured out how
important my message was
and just started delivering it.
That's it.
So I think it's knowing the content,
knowing it really well, and delivering it
to the person you're thinking of
and looking at them and saying it.
Using the camera that way,
and then you've done your job
in terms of personality.
Because it's just going to be
you talking to someone then.
- I like it.
Now, you've talked about the importance
of our message a couple times.
For people who aren't familiar
with your YouTube channel.
- [Amy] Sure.
- What is the message
of Savvy, Sexy, Social
when they come and check out your videos?
- So, I mean, I just want
you to come to my channel
and feel motivated and equipped
to go after the life you want.
- [Evan] Nice.
- And I do a lot of that
through teaching you
how to use different vehicles
of delivering your message
like social media and video.
But sometimes it's productivity
and time management.
Because sometimes we just can't figure out
how to fit everything in in a day.
And that really keeps
us from getting it done,
and therefore, we're not
going after the life we want.
I want everyone to feel like they can.
It's 2017.
If you're not happy with your life,
you can change it.
And you can make it happen,
but don't make yourself thing you can't.
Any video that I have delivers on that,
and I'm very adamant about
giving you something actionable
always because hyperbole is wonderful.
And it's motivational,
but at the same time,
I need somethin' here.
Like, give me somethin' to do right now
cause I'll do it.
I'll test it, and I will
let you know if it worked.
And I want my community to do that always.
So come to my channel.
If there's something you want to do
or something you want to say
or a change you want to make,
and you just need to know
how to do it.
- I like it.
Well, you have some fans
already in the chat.
Racquel Carter: I love Amy!
- [Amy] Thank you.
- Next question.
This is a super common question.
I don't know if you
address this in your book,
Vlog Like a Boss, but let me know.
Kensen, how do I figure out the
best camera and mics to use?
- I do talk about gear
although I almost thought,
like, wouldn't it be funny
if I did book about video
and didn't talk about gear?
Cause I'm always telling people, like,
stop worrying about the gear.
But here's the thing.
It, there's, it's a good conversation.
I'm going to start by saying
do what you can with what
you have where you are.
Theodore Roosevelt.
That's, I mean, like, that's what you need
to know right now.
I mean, it's 2017.
You have a way better camera
than I did when I started
10 years ago, okay. (laughs)
So just use the thing.
And that's the basis of
what I'm going to say.
There are tools to help
you edit on that phone.
You can edit on web browsers,
and the accessibility
is unmatched than ever before.
So there's that.
Prove to yourself that you need to upgrade
to get all the fancy gear.
Like, I make myself feel
the pain of not having gear
before I'll go buy it, so I know
I make every dollar worth it.
But that's when you know
it's time to upgrade.
And just get the camera
that you know how to use
and set up your space.
I love when people just pick
a corner of their office
or their house and the
camera just sits there
until they have somethin' to say,
and then they'll go stand
in front of it and say it.
Because that's really powerful
when you get into that habit,
which is what I've always had.
I've got my bookshelf.
When it's time to talk, camera up.
Let's go.
Lights on.
Talk.
And I think that's the best moment
you can capture with video.
If that's easier for you
with a smart phone, do it.
Because you've got it.
I mean, most of us do.
And so that's really important,
but prove to yourself
you need the fancy gear.
I absolutely have a chapter on that.
I also have a page on my
website dedicated to that.
But a lot of people will just
jump on buying that stuff
and not even know really
what to do with it.
I would challenge you to take action
on making video before you
worry about the equipment.
- I love it.
I agree.
- [Amy] Good.
- Mack writing in.
I'm starting a weight loss journey,
and I want to start vlogging my journey.
Do you think I'll have success on YouTube
showing my journey, and
do you have any tips
for me to start this?
- I absolutely think
there's success in that
because the greatest thing about a vlog
is you're just simply telling
a story no matter how it is.
And you are just simply doing that.
I just met someone the
other day that told their
transgender transformation story.
And that was just here's what's happening.
Just letting you know.
This is how I feel about it.
This is what's hard.
And I'm going to figure it out.
I feel like anyone that's
going through a process.
I just documented 31
days of launching a book.
That's a process, you
know, sharing that story.
People like to see that because
not only can you tell them
what you know, but they're
actually seeing the experience
happen, so they know you know.
And sometimes people need
that when might not have
as much confidence in
their thought leadership
on what they know.
If they feel like they're simply
telling you what happened,
then, we're all pretty
clear as the audience.
Like, well, that's what happened.
And that's how they feel,
and today's been a hard day.
Yesterday was a good day.
And it's nice to see that.
Weight loss journeys, that's
one of the most motivational
things I think you could watch on YouTube
because when you see someone
make a change in their life.
I think that's why a lot
of us gravitate toward
this platform and decide to
make video or tell our story
in some capacity because we've seen
what changes someone
has made in their life
simply by getting on video
and talking about it.
My tip would be,
and this is tough for me, too,
so I'll just put it out there.
Don't be afraid to get vulnerable,
which automatically what you're
doing is pretty vulnerable.
But I think you have to be really true
about what you're
feeling and not every day
is going to be a great day.
And you're going to know that.
It's so hard to look at the camera
and not be negative, I think.
I think we all want to be really positive,
but your, I think that your journey's
going to be more impactful for someone
if they really know what
they're signing up for.
If they're maybe followin'
in your footsteps.
And to hear you go,
like, I just want a piece
of freaking cake so bad.
(laughs)
I think being that transparent
is what gets people hooked,
and I would say don't be
afraid of that vulnerability.
- Cool.
J Green writing in.
How do you decide what videos to make?
- So a lot of it, I have
the fortunate luxury
of having a community
that tells me. (laughs)
You know, they will just
tell me all the time
what they want.
But what's my promise?
That's to make sure that
somebody learns something from me
and has a good time and can take action
on making a change in their life.
That's the promise that I've made.
So any video that I want
to make in that regard
falls into that category.
But at the same time, I'm a specialist
when it comes to online communication,
so it's going to be toward that area.
And then you can actually read in my book
about how I bucket content.
So what are the different categories
that I want to play in
and then when I come up
with a topic idea, it
goes into a category,
which lands in a place on
the editorial calendar.
And everything really
like plans itself out.
Instead of the run and gun, like, oh,
I'm going to do this video now.
I'm going to do that video now.
That can start to get a little exhausting
for people, and you won't
maybe stick with it.
So I do believe in the editorial calendar
and setting up for success.
And those are sort of
the, I plan my buckets.
And I put content in those buckets.
It's all about, you know,
bettering your life,
time management, social media, video,
and how can I help you do that right now?
Cause that's what I specialize in.
Go for it.
So that's how I come up
with what to talk about,
and you'll often find
when you do one video,
what happens in the
comments is they'll say
another question or they'll say,
wouldn't it be cool if
she did a video on this?
And it's just like, write that down.
Even if you're not ready for
it, or if it's down the road
or it's not quite a
fit, just write it down.
Because having that feedback is so huge.
It is such a blessing that
someone's telling you what to do
because they're saying we will watch that.
That's big.
So really leverage any opportunity to ask.
I always say when you
don't have a network yet.
Let's say you're starting with zero.
Go ask the people you know
what's the first question
you think of, or what's your
frequently asked question
about what you do really well?
Or see if they even know how
to articulate what you do.
When you ask people
that, they will tell you
what they're thinking, and usually,
that's what they're popping into Google
if that's ever an issue in their life.
And that's a good place to be
when you're making content.
What are people Googling
that you know how to answer?
That's content.
- I like it.
Impractical Jokers Full
Punishments is asking about
basically, how to use Facebook
to drive more YouTube views.
Do I upload the video to Facebook?
Is it just linking it to Facebook
and it hopefully goes to YouTube?
Is it doing short clips?
How do you use Facebook to
drive more YouTube views?
- So I've done a number of
different things for myself
for clients, and there's
something powerful
in being able to upload native video
because Facebook loves
native video right now.
So meaning, I'm going to
upload this clip to Facebook,
not to YouTube, but to Facebook.
I don't like to upload an
entire video to Facebook
unless it's been on YouTube
for a certain amount of time
cause that's where I
choose to put my momentum.
If you would prefer to grow
your Facebook platform,
then, go hard there and upload.
But I also would say that
you could do something
a little different and this
is really powerful right now
because of how much
Facebook loves live video.
Going live on Facebook and
saying, or while you're uploading
and saying, you know, answering questions
and saying, I just
posted a video on YouTube
and it's about this.
Do you guys have questions about this?
Or what do you guys think about it?
Or have you had any experience with this?
And having a real conversation
with people in Facebook.
All the while, your YouTube
link is in the caption
of that livestream, so that
you get a lot of momentum
on that post with the
live video on Facebook.
That's probably going
to be with engagement,
it could be on the feed for 24 hours
depending on how things go.
You've got that YouTube
link sitting there,
and you can get some traffic over.
I feel that's the best
way to get those links
clicked over from Facebook right now
because of how much Facebook likes live.
But I also love to just post my thumbnail,
and I will put the
YouTube link in a picture
of a thumbnail because a
photo is still technically
a native upload to Facebook.
So that still works for me sometimes.
Throughout the month of
documenting the launch
of the book though, we did
upload the full episodes
of the videos 24 to 48 hours
after it was on YouTube
because there was just so
much content to work with,
and we were moving and shaking a lot.
So it's the kind of video
that can pull someone in
on the newsfeed.
That that helped as well.
But that wasn't so much
for a YouTube view.
It was just awareness of the book.
So think about what the main goals are,
and then, think about,
okay well, what's the,
if the main goal is to get
attention on this book,
then we're just going
to do whatever it takes.
If it's for the YouTube
view, how do you make sure
that it gets there efficiently?
- I like it.
Hod92, any hints on how to
find the message you want
to deliver in your videos, Amy?
- I think you will get
a huge hint if you know
who you're talking to very specifically.
And knowing who your
avatar is, what they do,
what their life is like, and
what keeps them up at night.
That's going to help shape your message.
I think you know what you do well.
And then knowing the person
that you're doing this for
well is going to help
you figure out exactly
what your thing is.
So I'll give you an example of my channel.
When I first started, I needed a platform
to become a professional in my industry.
And at the time, the customers
that I was working with
were small businesses in 2010 and 2011
that wanted nothing to
do with social media.
They were told they
needed a Facebook page.
They certainly weren't
ready for video yet,
but what do we do with
this Facebook situation?
They needed to learn that.
They didn't have a budget for it,
and they just needed
to do it on their own.
What I needed to do to show
up and be now considered
one of the top leaders in the space
was make it fun for them
because they were doing
all this research, and it was a nightmare
and they weren't excited.
And I just said, I'm going
to teach you how to use
that Facebook page, but
you're going to have fun
while you're learning it from me.
So that was really that, the first thing
that happened for me, so I knew I knew
how to manage a Facebook page.
So I'll teach you how.
But I also know who you are.
You're a business owner.
Maybe you've got a brick and mortar.
This is a total nightmare
that someone's being told
there's a new marketing
platform you need to use
and you need to use it now.
So let's have fun in this process.
I'm going to make my video
short because I know you don't
have time, and every
single one is going to have
a tactic for you to take forward.
All of those things came together
as the message of the channel.
And then, you're really getting focused
around who they are, which
is the most important thing.
But also, what you're best at.
I think people start to get in trouble
when they go, oh, that sounds good,
but they're not the expert on that thing,
or they're not quite as
experienced on that thing,
but they still try to make a video on it.
You want to make sure
someone feels the impact
and gets the results from
you every single time.
So stay focused on what you're good at.
But really understand
where they're coming from.
- I like it.
Now, tying into the last
question about having fun
and that being your angle.
Onassis is writing in.
Should I present myself as a friendly guy
or professional guy?
- I think it should be both
because I think we've learned
in social media that
people want to do business
with a person.
As fluffy as that sounds, right.
You know, we see fewer logos
these days and more faces,
and I think that's super important.
So you should be friendly
because nobody wants
to work with someone that's not friendly.
But you can be professional
and friendly as well.
And you can be professional and friendly
and stand up for what
you believe in as well.
And so, I think all of the above.
- I agree 100%.
Can we focus on two
subjects on our channel,
and how can we do that?
- Usually, when this question pops up,
I feel like it's because someone's like,
do I just come up with a second channel,
or should we kind of exert
energy in two places?
And I feel these days in
YouTube it's so much easier
to have different kinds
of content on one channel
because of the way that it works.
That being said, the only
reason why two subjects
would be on one channel is if
they serve the same people.
So if you want to make those two subjects
your, sort of, brand, and maybe
they sound eclectic together.
That could be the case.
And you're like, who is
doing something like this?
Well, if you're the first,
awesome, but make it work
because it's for the one
person that's going to find it.
And they're going to love it.
But if you're like, we're going
to talk about dog supplies,
and we're going to talk
about buying paper.
If those two things are
not for the same person,
then maybe they shouldn't
be on the same channel.
I think that's how you determine that.
- I like it.
That's a really good distinction.
Leroy, how are you able
to get out of your own way
in taking that first
step in your business?
- Well, I think I was fortunate
that people were coming
to me and wanted advice
while I had a full-time job.
And a lot of people think that it's like
when you make the jump
into entrepreneurship,
it's big and scary.
It certainly is, but I did
a lot of work leading up
to that big, scary decision
even though it was still
big and scary at that time.
In order to get out of
my own way, I think I had
to do the work and prove to
myself that I could actually
execute on what I was selling
and not just say like,
I'm going to start a business and think
that everyone was coming my way.
So I actually did a lot of client work
as what we're calling
these days a side hustle.
At the time, it was just
like, what I did at night,
the passion project.
But I did that for about a year and a half
before I finally made the
leap to leaving my job.
And I took a long time
to be like, oh, my god,
I think I'm going to leave my job.
This is so crazy, but it still
took me like a whole year
to get to that point.
The getting out of my own way happened
when I just did the work,
and I said, now is the time.
I have measured my risk, reward, you know.
I didn't have a mortgage.
I didn't have any kids.
And I could kind of make a
big, kind of scary decision
at the time, and some people
don't have that luxury.
I think that's what it comes down to.
I got out of my own way cause
I measured the risk, reward,
and I did the work, and I met people.
And as soon as I left that
job, I had full-time work
coming in as what it was
freelancing really at the time.
Because I'd met people.
I'd told them I was going out on my own.
I said, I'm available for hire.
Do you know anyone that needs this?
And I got out of my own
way by pitching myself.
And that's probably
hardest for most people.
Selling yourself is not
something that we brush up on
when we think of entrepreneurship.
We just think we're going to
write a bunch of blog posts
and make videos and maybe
business will come in.
You got to sell yourself,
too, and so I think
that's a big obstacle a
lot of people have to hit.
- I love it.
Amy, it's crazy how 1/2 an hour flies by
when we're chatting.
- [Amy] It flew by.
- You're getting a ton of love.
Thanks Evan and Amy.
- Thank you.
- You've helped me a lot.
Great questions from everyone.
Great answers.
I want to put the last one on you.
I want to talk about Vlog Like a Boss,
and I want people to check it out.
- [Amy] Yeah.
- Got to VlogLikeaBoss.com or Amazon
or wherever you buy books.
What's something, what's
an important message
from Vlog Like a Boss
that we haven't touched on
in this chat that you think is important
for people who want to
have Youtube success
that they should know about?
- I think people try to
figure out how to be creative
these days in video.
And like, there's going
to be a clearcut answer.
But the epitome of
creativity is truly trying
to find where you are an original.
And I think I've found a
couple ways that I do that,
but instead of asking someone
else or asking yourself
how am I going to stand out?
How am I going to be creative?
I think you have to do the work
because that is going to show up for you.
You're going to come up
with the craziest ideas,
and video is the most fun
and exciting ways to kind of
bring them to life and
have people discover you.
And that's the scariest
thing about the fact
that you're doing this is
not only are you so bold
as to make video, but you're
bold enough to be creative.
But that creativity is
going to take you places
that you've never been before.
So as cut and dry and as black and white
as you might want it to be.
Here are all the steps,
and I give you a lot
of freakin' steps in this book.
You're also just going to find like,
how did you even come up with that idea?
It's just going to happen for you,
and when you feel that moment
of if someone made this
and it wasn't me, and
it wasn't my company.
If someone made this,
I would even share it
with my community.
That's how you know you
have something good.
Something so shareable, you would share it
with your friends and family.
That's how you know you're
on to something good.
And that's how you know you're creative.
And to go after that
idea and allow yourself
to stand out.
We're going to stumble.
We're going to think things are
cool that aren't always cool.
But your creativity is
going to come out so hard
when you use this medium,
and I hope you'll fully embrace it.
- I love it.
Boom.
Nice, final message.
- [Amy] Thank you.
- Thank you guys so much for watching,
for asking all those great questions.
I encourage you to go
check out VlogLikeaBoss.com
on Amazon or wherever
you go buy your books.
- [Amy] Yay.
- Amy, oh, Amy's showing up books.
You got to say something
to show up on camera.
- Oh, get the book, please.
(laughs)
- There it is.
There it is.
Amy, thank you for your time as well.
Guys, continue to believe,
and we'll see you soon.